direktkandidatin wie wird man das über
die erststimme werden die gewinner innen
im wahlkreis direkt in den bundestag
gewählt daher heißen die menschen auf
dem wahlzettel direktkandidat
beziehungsweise direktkandidatin um dort
zu landen muss nicht unbedingt
parteimitglied sein man muss die
deutsche staatsbürgerschaft besitzen und
man muss über 18 sein dann gibt es zwei
möglichkeiten entweder eine partei
stellt die person auf dann müssen die
parteimitglieder aus einem wahlkreis sie
in geheimer wahl wählen parteien
bevorzugen hier meistens natürlich ihre
eigenen mitglieder sie setzten auch
schon bekannte gesichter um sich eine
stimme zu sichern der weg ohne partei
läuft anders man braucht dann mindestens
die unterschrift von 200
wahlberechtigten aus dem wahlkreis in
dem man sich bewirbt einzelbewerber
innen sind jedoch die ausnahme und meist
chancenlos
seit der ersten bundestagswahl 1949 kam
so niemand mehr in den bundestag